Classroom 410: Waiting for our guest speaker. So last class of the semester whose last class of the entire semester is this, today
Classroom 410: we have anybody got one person.
Classroom 410: The rest of you have classes tomorrow. I'm assuming.
Classroom 410: No, I'm confused about your answers.
Classroom 410: Yes, as well. So a couple of things
Classroom 410: with with regards to the final exam that is released actually, 2 min ago. You can take it same same thing. You can take it anytime between now and literally we had the last slide in of all final exams that there was out there. So if we did the traditional sit down exam, you would have been having it on the 17.th Yeah.
Classroom 410: so we are leaving it open. Then, if you want to take it, then that is perfectly fine.
Classroom 410: but just out of curiosity. And of course I'm not going to hold this to you, but we're just trying to do a quick, strong poll who thinks they're going to take the final exam next week.
Classroom 410: So the majority of you who thinks they're going to take the final exam the week after that they can't
Classroom 410: few of you. Okay, that's perfectly fine. Who's gonna take it on the 17? th
Classroom 410: Is there anyone? Okay? Maybe meals in for the 17?
Classroom 410: So that's good. Any questions about the final. Do we have them here? Okay, any questions about the final before I turn over?
Classroom 410: Yeah. Any previews for us, any previews, hot tips.
Classroom 410: No, so I haven't been drinking, so I don't know if this will help you.
Classroom 410: You know what I'll say about the final. You've seen this before, but now we're looking for more depth.
Classroom 410: That would be my hot tip for you folks. You know how to approach it. It'll ask you to bring a whole bunch of things together. Now it's time to figure out
Classroom 410: unlike other classes. I really really like grading. Unlike all other classes, I really like grading this final exam, because it's like they get it like, everything's coming together. They could be in a meeting with other security people. And they could answer that question, and that's a good answer. And I think we've accomplished what we've accomplished in this class. If you can do that for 4 or 5 different types of things. Yep.
Classroom 410: yeah, it's kind of like this class is. It's hard to pretend like something like it's all cumulative in a way. Right? Yep. Did you end up posting like good responses to exam questions? Yeah. So I have example. If you go and do gradescope, I have example answers for all of them under that rubric. It'll show you, and the answers are lengthy. So there's a lot. I spent a lot of time providing responses, so it'll hurt my feelings if you don't read them
Classroom 410: 2 h. Yep.
Classroom 410: the exam is designed to be 90 min, and we give you 2 h of flight in case computer goes down. You don't practice very rarely. Will you run out of time?
Classroom 410: You'll run out of time because you're stuck, which is, that's a different issue more of an emphasis on like one particular unit than the others like.
Classroom 410: And you're asking me to remember things
Classroom 410: like, I don't know, like, like we talked a lot about like like more emphasis on like beginning of the like, the beginning modules. No, they're kind of equally balanced as my design. Between them. There's some amazing stuff from Professor Lewis, some amazing stuff for me. And then, when we did it jointly, there's some stuff there.
Classroom 410: My stuff's not patient.
Classroom 410: Alright, I think we have you with us.
Em: Oh! Hi!
Classroom 410: Whoa! You're here!
Em: I am here.
Em: Oh, I'm so blurry. Okay, there we are.
Classroom 410: It's good to see you again.
Em: Yeah.
Classroom 410: So Em joins us from Cisa as we talked about last class. So she's here to talk about all things that Cisa does under dhs. And the other thing about what's great about them is, Em will talk to you about what the career actually looks like, what the job's actually like. So, Em, without further ado, I'll turn it over to you to talk about yourself.
Em: thanks, Ryan. I didn't know Brian was gonna be here. So hey, Brian? So my name is MI work at Cisa. We were previously
Em: a component of the Department of Homeland Security, and I started working here as an intern. In 2017.
Em: They liked me enough and offered me a full-time job. So that's like that's like the dream, right? Like you get an internship. You get. You get the full-time offer, and you're you're like doing cyber security and so I work within
Em: threat hunting at Cisa, which is
Em: we get called the big sexy, and it is pretty much there's it's not
Em: penetration testing. That's a vulnerability management which is like our sister organization. So we
Em: we have. We get like a tip.
Em: probably from our own sensors or our intelligence partners say, there's there's been an intrusion.
Em: and we get called in, as we're like the cyber swat team or ghostbusters, whatever you want to call it
Em: and we do not eradicate the threat. But we we stop the bleed. We're like, we're basically like, I would say, Emts.
Em: So we go in, we take a look at everything. We ask for copies of logs. We
Em: make sure that we can contain the issue, and then we generate a report
Em: and document our findings and our recommendations. We don't. We are also not law enforcement. So if we come across any unscrupulous activity, we're we're not gonna like call the cops. And we actually.
Classroom 410: Purposely
Em: Break things that would allow
Em: our findings to be presented in a court of like in a court. We don't act as professional witnesses. We pretty much do it.
Em: Because I would say, we really love the mission. There's there's still like do-gooders.
Em: In the government.
Em: And yeah, I mean, I'll start with that. I I was your your alum. Chris Krebs
Em: was famously fired by Tweet, and he was the our former director. So I used to run in to him on the bike path and like,
Em: so so yeah, I was working under him when he was ousted for basically posting a blog on Cis, denouncing.
Em: like disinformation about elections and kudos to Ryan for giving me this slot in December, because.
Em: as you know, we had an election this year, and that was it was.
Em: It was hot and heavy over at Cisa, so I'm glad to be here, glad to have eaten like 2 pumpkin pies.
Em: and to like have have some time since the 6.th
Em: But I'm ready to take your questions.
Classroom 410: All right. Well, I'll start so specifically about the election. What? What is Cis's role in securing elections? And can you tell us anything
Classroom 410: cool that you've done the last month or so.
Em: Absolutely so. Yo, I
Em: I never really thought about elections.
Em: And until I think, like 2016,
Em: politics seemed like just a thingy, that happened. It seemed pretty boring. And then 2,016 happened.
Em: And I felt like I I needed to like, do something I need to like work for the government, and like figure
Em: and like, do do cybersecurity at like a level that wasn't just like
Em: at a small company like trying to trying to like
Em: do it, which was what I was doing at the time. So
Em: since joining in 2,017, we've homeland security has been
Em: has been tasked with securing critical infrastructures, of which elections is one of them.
Em: We have been since then
Em: meeting with State partners, so you meet at the State level. There's 50 States, and then DC. In the United States. And if you've seen one election
Em: you've seen one election, so elections are different in each State. So it's not just the year that the election happens in. It's like
Em: all the years before it. Right? You've if you've got to secure 51 areas of how
Em: the election's going to happen. You've got to be meeting with basically potentially 51 groups of partners. And then there's like State and elections happen at all the different levels. There is like this, there's the Presidential election
Em: for, like the Federal level. But then there's also state elections that happen more often than every 4 years. So we really think about, I think, as a country like the Presidential election every 4 years. But there's many small elections that happen all the time, and then also special elections. So
Em: there's a lot there was a lot of like tabletop exercising.
Em: And we're I have this joke. We're kind of like we're like vampires. We have to be invited in.
Em: So
Em: that doesn't mean that we only work with like blue States or Red States like, we're not partisan
Em: so, but we do have to be allowed in. We don't. We can't barge in and say, like, we're we're going to secure your election. We're going to do it like it is.
Em: It is a conversation, and we do have to work with partners, and they're partners. They're not like underlings.
Em: So this year especially, or at least I think so. Back in 2016 we did find that there was election interference from Russia, and that's been proven, and this year it has.
Em: I would I would say that election interference has continued, but not in ways that are like, I would say the
Em: people think it's not like someone voted for Candidate A, and then, like all the votes actually counted for Candidate B.
Em: I think election interference these days is, it can be much more insidious. And it's more psychological.
Em: And that's not. That's not like
Em: that's not necessarily cyber security in the zeros and ones sense. It's not like the computers are lying. It's not necessarily
Em: the most obvious type of computer crime. But like, I'm sure Professor Ryan and Professor Brian have spoken about like the the human side of security, and
Em: how our minds are fallible. And we're all humans with biases and
Em: and our own experiences. So I think
Em: when we talk about election security
Em: while it is air gapping and having contingency plans, for if there's a flood, if there's a if there's a bomb threat. There is also
Em: making sure that we can get the American people to understand the truth. And what is happening, and how are we
Em: working with election officials who are a lot of times volunteers. They're just people. There are a lot of
Em: people that show up on just election day which who have to go through
Em: several trainings, and they they're the ones to say, Hi, how are you? And they help you get to the polls.
Em: Depending on the state you're in, like they give you the right ballot. So it's
Em: it is about, I think, people this year.
Em: and that's that that seems like it's been a bigger shift towards that.
Classroom 410: Yep
Classroom 410: so, and I'll turn it over to students. But I do want to ask. You know, there's a lot of talent in this room. Obviously you're a very talented person. Why, why, the government like what? What interests you about working for the Government versus.
Classroom 410: you know, making may maybe a little bit more in the private sector.
Em: Sure. This is a cool and personal question. So thank you. So I have. I have an Mba. And I was getting my Mba. At the time that I met
Em: Brian, and there was a scholarship that was being offered. It's called the Cyber Core Scholarship for Service program, and I wanted to be in it, and there was a different Brian
Em: at the University of Massachusetts, who was a professor of computer science, and he said to me, why would you want to do this? You're getting an Mba. You could make like a million dollars.
Em: And you'll you'll find out, unfortunately, that it's like. It's not as easy as that.
Em: But I
Em: felt as a person of color and a person of the LGBT community that I was an American, too. And
Em: I wanna like, get into
Em: serving people of this country. And I think when you think of service work, you probably think of like being in the military
Em: and that's not the same right. I don't put my life on the line
Em: for my job, but I do dedicate my time, and I do think about all the people that live in this nation that look or don't look like me, and think, or don't think like me, and I want them to like
Em: would be able to live their lives every day in this country.
Em: So I mean.
Classroom 410: That's why government and I like working around people that.
Em: You know, also like look or don't look like me, think, or don't think like me, but also want to have this mission to like preserve people's lifestyles like
Em: I. I like living in a community where some people would agree or disagree with me. I don't. I don't want to live somewhere where, like everyone's the same, and says the same stuff, and thinks the same thing.
Classroom 410: All right. I'll open it up
Classroom 410: questions for M. About her role at Cisa, or about Cisa, or about life.
Classroom 410: But
Classroom 410: sure, hey, I'm good to see. I'm sitting way in the back of the room so you could probably hopefully you you remember my voice. So
Classroom 410: you know you started this journey.
Classroom 410: My math is right. It's like a decade ago. Does that sound about right as far as it being at how long you been at Cisa for.
Em: I've been there since 17, so I mean almost a decade, but not yet.
Classroom 410: Not yet. So yeah, so what do you? What's been the biggest change in that organization over the last 7 or 8 years that you've seen with everything that's gone on, has there been?
Classroom 410: And then the second question, What's
Classroom 410: how have the attacks changed over the 7 or 8 years.
Em: Absolutely. That's a great question. Thanks. So I think. Hands down. It was the pandemic. That was the biggest thing that just rocked the whole world right? It wasn't just
Em: wasn't just me. But like overnight, basically, like I had to like.
Em: we just didn't have the policy for it, like from a standpoint like we just nobody did. No one was like suddenly, like March of 2020. We've got to shut down
Em: and no one can go outside and we're gonna work
Em: in our homes. I mean, luckily, we're we're like a technology agency. So everyone
Em: had laptops. We already had the provisions to work remote. Because, like, we have like VPN set up. And really, what we did was we just like ordered everyone
Em: an extra monitor, a keyboard, and a mouse.
Em: so that you could. You could work more efficiently without, like a 50 inch screen and like a little trackpad.
Em: so that worked all right for for us. But that increased like the load on our networks.
Em: So we had. It was. It was bumpy for everyone, but it also showed that, like we can be really resilient. And
Em: continued to meet the mission even when
Em: we're not meeting with our partners in person all the time. But it's it's not like the technology wasn't there. And like we weren't already having partners that weren't in the same time zone. And we had to like figure out a time to meet and
Em: like do our stuff. I think the hardest part was that we have
Em: some secure facilities that cannot be accessed from outside. So we did have to have people go in
Em: in person, but that's a smaller number.
Em: And how the attacks have changed. I mean, generative AI is is huge. And this was something that
Em: we were talking about when I started so 7 years ago, and you didn't really see it. And it wasn't like
Em: chat. Gpt wasn't like you couldn't just sign up for free but
Em: generative AI, I think, is like the
Em: really you're really starting to see it happen. Because you can.
Em: you can launch an attack and change strategies in real time, like no longer. Our adversaries have, like a certain footprint that we expect, whether it's like
Em: timestamps, right? Like we used to be able to see attacks happen 5 days a week during
Em: certain hours. So then, you're like, if this.
Em: this is someone's job, then this is someone's 9 to 5. And then you think about
Em: like, what? What part of the world would this be? A 9 to 5? And maybe
Em: they work, they're only attacking 6 days a week. So then, you're like, well, maybe
Em: this, these attacks are coming from a country that observes one day of the week where they don't work. So is this, does this mean that they might have a certain like religious influence in this country, so we could pinpoint things easier.
Em: whereas now we sort of have to pinpoint things by like, what is the target? What is the pattern of the targets? What are they trying to get.
Classroom 410: Thank you.
Classroom 410: I'm anon I'm a 4th year. I'm doing Cs and it in the Comp school. I'm kind of curious more on the personal side, being in this type of work for almost a decade, does.
Classroom 410: I guess the weariness of like how many attacks you've seen over the years come into your own personal life. Do you have anxiety around? I guess what I'm asking is like. Would you rather have had ignorance towards all of this cyber security related attacks.
Classroom 410: That's kind of what I'm asking. Or do you set up anything for your personal life in a way that stops these attacks.
Em: That's that's such an awesome question. Thank you. Because
Em: Before the pandemic, like, we'd have more parties, and like a couple times a year we'd go to my boss's house, and he'd
Em: he'd invite everyone, and he would continue to invite people that had left the organization. And so
Em: I talked to these people. We stay in touch because, you know, the world is still kind of small
Em: and people that have left our organization say that, like, I like working at like Amazon, or whatever because I couldn't sleep at night.
Em: and now I can sleep at night. I can sleep at night with my 3 cars, 2 garage house like whatever and like they just.
Em: I don't know, do like data architecture.
Em: So I would say that absolutely like this is not for everyone. I think this year was especially tough.
Em: mentally, I can see across the organization people.
Em: People did leave
Em: we had some attrition more than usual this year from Feds, and also contractors. For sure, I think
Em: not. Everyone has the stomach for this work.
Em: And I am an ultra athlete. I raced bicycles. I did
Em: a race this year, where I covered like
Em: a hundred 25 miles in like 12 h.
Classroom 410: Yeah, cause it was like, really mountainous.
Em: So. And I joke that like, that's how I can do the work I do. So like.
Em: Maybe with lots of disassociation. Sometimes, like I do like have a system where I I try to like
Em: like literally escape from technology, right? Like, if I'm like in a remote place, and no one can find me
Em: to let me know that there was a breach. And we're having a national emergency like
Em: sometimes, like, you know, some people do do that, and some people at my work are like Marathon runners. I think I think you'll find that like
Em: to to take care of our mental health like a lot of people do turn to exercise.
Classroom 410: Others. Hi, I'm my name is Matt. I'm 4th year studying finance and it here. My question is kind of 2 parted.
Classroom 410: 1st I think you kind of touched on it, but I'm just curious to hear, like the chain of command within Cisa and then kind of stemming from that question.
Classroom 410: I've said that you said you started in 2017 and now there's like a different President than there was then, and I'm kind of curious of like as that changes. Do the roles of your job change or like? Do you see, like the initiatives change
Classroom 410: within Cisco.
Em: Sure. Yeah. So
Em: The Christopher Krebs, like level now, is Jen easterly. She is the director of Cisa, and below her
Em: our divisions, and so within Cisa I work under the Cybersecurity division. That's Csd.
Em: and then under Csd, I work at threat hunting, and I have a director there and then.
Em: threat hunting is actually split into threat and hunt. So threat is more like, I would say, left of boom. It's more proactive, and then Hunt is like
Em: something has hit the fan we've got to deploy. Let's go. So I work at the threat hunting level in sort of like I've got like 250 people reporting to me. But I also have to report up to
Em: talk about our outcomes and our metrics, and like foresee any issues in terms of
Em: how my work is going to change with the incoming administration. I I've seen 2 now and
Em: you know, I think I imagine cyber security could become
Em: more bearish, maybe less congressional funding coming to Cisa.
Em: I can. I've been.
Em: There's been some mutterings that
Em: we won't focus as much on election security. Moving forward, you can. You can take what you want about that
Em: and probably focusing more on China.
Classroom 410: Are we got time for one or 2 more sorry. So we just completed a case for class today. Actually, that was discussing like Gdpr, and sort of like some of the policies that, like America, wants to take like moving forward for like regulation, for consumer privacy, and one of the perspectives that, like that, one of the perspectives in the case was like a governmental or like law enforcement agency, which actually like we had, I had to do for my portion.
Classroom 410: I was just like curious like, what is your take like working at as a slash like? And I like a government agency on what
Classroom 410: we should be doing, moving forward in terms of like, how much data companies have, how much information consumers are giving and like, whether or not that poses a risk for, like nation, state actors.
Em: Oh, yeah, absolutely. So I mentioned earlier that, like, we don't do law enforcement and
Em: homeland security is not so much internationally reaching as we are more domestic.
Em: But that said like I can give you my my like personal take on it like
Em: I think the right to be forgotten, right? Like you being able to have control over your data is important. Because, like.
Em: I mean, even if you search yourself on these like people, find our websites like
Em: you can ask to like you can, you can look yourself up.
Em: And then you're gonna be. You might be surprised that, like the information they find they're gonna like for free. Right? Like you could find your identity, you can find all. Probably most of the addresses you've been associated with. You can find
Em: utilities that you've been using your phone number, your
Em: birthday, your associated social media accounts. And then people that you have been associated with. And
Em: I do search for myself regularly and like request that I get deleted off those websites, and I do.
Em: But new websites come up right. So it's like, if there's this
Em: open source information, you at least need to have
Em: some sort of way to like, get rid of it. And like
Em: we live in the digital world. We all get spam. You get spam to your phone. You get spam to your emails, you know, like
Em: these companies are just like selling it to make more money. So I think we like personally like.
Em: I think we should protect consumers. Because if we don't, and we're just being run by like
Em: organizations that profit off us like
Em: without our consent, like. It's 1 thing for me to purchase a product or service because I want it.
Em: But it's another thing that like
Em: to like secretly or unknowingly agree to have.
Em: like, basically the metadata around that purchase sold
Em: like and continue being profited off of. So though that's that's my personal. Take on it like
Em: I think, like a lot of folks that work at the Government would feel like
Em: reasons why you would be an American is to like, have certain freedoms. So
Em: I think if you dig deep enough like, they might agree with me.
Classroom 410: Second.
Classroom 410: Alright, I can still the last one, if there's no more.
Classroom 410: These are generally short responses, but I'll try. So, Em, it's been 3 and a half years since the colonial pipeline attack. Can you tell us any more about Cis's role in that remediation, or is that your answer still going to be. I can't comment on that.
Em: You got it.
Classroom 410: I tried.
Classroom 410: Okay? Well, m. 1 more question. We'll go to the back room. Hi, my name is Jess. I'm a master's in accounting student. I was wondering, as consumers going forward like, what would you recommend from your perspective that we establish or
Classroom 410: install to prevent any attacks on our side can't read it, or for small businesses.
Em: Okay.
Em: I think it's less about like the services that you're gonna install and more about like where you put yourself in the 1st place. So making sure that you've got separate things for separate
Em: functions right? Like, maybe you don't set up a shared email for every single person in your organization to
Em: receive invoices or pay invoices because you want to be able to track. Who's doing that? So
Em: just making sure your access control
Em: is there, and and really like, plan out,
Em: the roles and responsibilities. I think so. If
Em: you've got an email address where you get like all like, where you do all your shopify, but also pay your bills and also get like
Em: like your financial stuff, too, like that's
Em: that's such a honeypot for someone who wants to get information about you.
Em: So thinking about like
Em: being an individual having separate email accounts for like your work and your play that typically like when when you start work at an organization, they give you an email address. But like making sure you don't like. Then sign up that email address for, like lots of personal stuff.
Em: That should be like one on one. But like sometimes I don't. I don't even see that on like it security trainings. And then so and then for, like a small business, making sure that everyone gets their own like credit card it's not just one credit card that everyone is using. So
Em: you want to just make sure that, like, there's no one person that can like.
Em: It's probably a negative way to pose it as like you don't want one person to screw everyone over. So I'm going to say that, like you don't want to
Em: open your risk to one person like potentially taking advantage of everything.
Classroom 410: On a bigger scale. What is your guys's process for deploying like a team? If there's an attack
Classroom 410: cause it's more on the hunting side.
Em: Sure. So on the hunting side, the 1st thing we do is usually victim notification. So we'll reach out to the organization. Say, like, hey.
Em: we've got an indicator of compromise for your organization.
Em: We have these services we want to do. And sometimes they're like, Yeah, we
Em: we're like fire eyes on it like we're we. We've got our own folks like we'll deal with it, and then we're like, cool, all right, and we back off
Em: Otherwise, if they want our help, we do require them to sign a memo of understanding
Em: go through, and it usually requires a couple of rounds with their lawyers,
Em: and their lawyers are always like. No, we don't want you to come in and
Em: do these things to our data, and then
Em: they never win. So if they want us to come in, they have to
Em: basically sign our paperwork, and then we go in depending on the compromise.
Em: We can deploy within 24 h. And so we have like a
Em: big list. We'd we'd take a look at pretty much like the footprint of the organization like, do they have assets in the cloud? Are they mostly a mom and pop shop?
Em: do they have like an extensive network footprint?
Em: And so we've we pretty much like, pick our analysts. Like.
Em: if you were to like, choose your team in a video game, we've got cloud analysts. We've got host analysts. We've got network analysts we have Ics analysts, so that Ics is like, it's like
Em: special computing that you would see more in like power plants.
Em: This is this is like, or like, yeah, definitely like, nuclear type power plants. You, that's much more specialized computing.
Em: And then we we would put that team together
Em: get probably like a writer on that team, and then someone to lead the team. And we'll we have
Em: a analyst kit that we deploy. We send that out by Fedex.
Em: It's like.
Em: It's like 4 stacks of servers. We have couple vans. So if it's like within 3 States or something we can drive. We'll load it up into a van and we'll we'll drive over.
Em: Otherwise people are flying.
Em: People are up in the air.
Classroom 410: All right and well, we got to talk about the pandemic and cyber crime and all kinds of stuff today. So let me lead the way, give me a round of applause. Thank you for for
Classroom 410: good to see you always good to talk to. You, appreciate it.
Em: Thanks everyone, bye.
Classroom 410: He's the only one to talk about something.
Classroom 410: yeah.
Classroom 410: okay, we're good. Okay. So if
Classroom 410: you know one of the things that Em is great about is, we used to take groups of students up to see the CIA and some other government organizations great careers there. If you want to think about that career path. Em is always happy to talk to people, but it's a path that a lot of commerce students never think about, because, you know the government, I could make double, triple, quadruple what they make. But in this type of role in Cisa they pay fairly well for the government.
Classroom 410: So, anyway, Emma's always happy to talk to students going forward.
Classroom 410: Alright. I assigned you a 2 page case.
Classroom 410: Wasn't that awesome? 2 page case for the last day of class. What was it about? Who can sum it up for me in 30 seconds or less?
Classroom 410: 15 seconds or less?
Classroom 410: Anybody read it
Classroom 410: alright. We got it. It's kind of a debate between, like big companies like Apple and Google. They were using some technology with Bluetooth for contract tracing for Covid. And there were some other entities like the French government. That kind of wanted more extreme policing of this data so that they could, you know, have effective tracking. And it was kind of how Apple and Google against that and weighing the pros and cons of that
Classroom 410: perfect. So thank you so much.
Classroom 410: So what I did was I put you by group into a persona and asked you a few questions about this, you know, to put on the hat of an organization.
Classroom 410: So I'll do the same thing in this room. So you can talk to each other about this.
Classroom 410: But in your persona, within your group. Please have a conversation about this statement, and we'll come back in a couple minutes and talk about the United States would be in a better position if we adopted Gdpr type legislation that is in place for the 27 members of the
Classroom 410: so discuss.
Classroom 410: I don't know. I think.
Classroom 410: Okay.
Classroom 410: I think it's gotten quiet enough. So who? Which of my groups were the government and law enforcement? All right, what's your take on this statement?
Classroom 410: We said that the Us. Government would typically be anti adopting the Gdpr type legislation. That's because, like we as like a governmental agency, and because, like the patriot act like want access to all this information.
Classroom 410: And like, if hackers are gonna be able to like, yeah, access to databases that have like consumer and like consumer private information that could be that use against like the Us. Government like we would want it first.st
Classroom 410: And so like increasing legislation around that, like increasing the privacy laws that, like consumers, have like limits, like the Us. Government's ability to like, interfere, and like, look at communications or not
Classroom 410: interfere. I like that word.
Classroom 410: Other government takes
Classroom 410: still, government or no. Okay, which which group are you? Oh, we're the consumer. All right. Let's let's a rebuttal from our consumer. So we kind of said like we wanted to like, adopt, like a more like Gdp, like legislation, because it also like allows us to like
Classroom 410: give consent to how much data we want like businesses to like have it also gives us like the right to be forgotten, like we don't want all of our data to like for our businesses to have it and then use it for like like bad stuff like, and also protects us from like risk of like data, breaches as well and like potential like identity. Theft.
Classroom 410: Is anyone in here a citizen of the EU?
Classroom 410: And have you ever invoked your right to be forgotten? No, okay, all right? So we got a consumer view. We got a government view. What about our large corporations? Who are they?
Classroom 410: What are your thoughts on this statement?
Classroom 410: So we were all kind of convinced that
Classroom 410: it might well, it might be good for the Government to have the kind of Gdpr style law, just because it would simplify completely
Classroom 410: compliance with, compared to the current
Classroom 410: kind of patchwork system that we have where it's different by state.
Classroom 410: But
Classroom 410: on the other hand, it would be really expensive and really high, costly to implement all that into our systems, and to make sure all of our branches and all of our subsidiaries are following the same laws, and it would also,
Classroom 410: really interfere with our ability to collect certain types of data that we need to have on our customers. So for you, okay, so it was a mixed bag. Yeah. So yes, it would make regulations easier, because you would have one instead of potentially 51. But on the other side it's going to cost money, and it may cost you customers. The ability to sell any other takes from a large corporations.
Classroom 410: Anybody
Classroom 410: also more so like it depends as well. Oh, I like, that's a faculty answer. But you know, I just like the just. The idea of having
Classroom 410: a consistent, you know, having consistency throughout would be really beneficial, because
Classroom 410: you don't have to worry about different laws and regulation different
Classroom 410: states where all the you can have your corporations in all those States. But then, at the same time, you.
Classroom 410: even though you will be able to build consumer, trust.
Classroom 410: With this you also have to then
Classroom 410: have. There's so much due to regulations where it's like, you don't have that much data. And as a large corporations, probably trying to grow. You know.
Classroom 410: your having data is, it's really good. But same time it's like
Classroom 410: not having. It's a smaller pool of data that you have to collect. And then it's like.
Classroom 410: yeah, for a large corporation. They do have like primary data. So they have to worry worry about things like as like other corporations. So if you think about
Classroom 410: it, might be kind of hard for them to actually grow
Classroom 410: so mixed bag as well. All right. Yeah, I was kind of on the side where, like, more data is just overall, more beneficial to the company. Just because you can make like
Classroom 410: more personalized customer experiences and like it helps the company run more efficiently. So like
Classroom 410: a comprehensive data, privacy law would kind of
Classroom 410: limit the amount of data that impinge that perhaps.
Classroom 410: But you know, you know to the point made before, if I have a data breach
Classroom 410: in the United States, and I do business with customers in all 50 States. How many attorney generals might I have to notify?
Classroom 410: Hmm.
Classroom 410: 50.
Classroom 410: That's fun. Right? Let's keep going. I'm also on the large corporation side and kind of on top of all the other points that were said. I also mentioned how we wouldn't want to like voluntarily put ourselves in a position where, if we were to somehow violate this rule, we'd have to pay like a large punitive consequence. Nobody mentioned that. Yet. So Gdpr is 4% potential fines of global revenue. Does that worry you guys as large corporations?
Classroom 410: I mean, that's a large amount like, so as we talk through these cases and these settlements.
Classroom 410: these, these fines that companies are receiving in the United States are so minuscule that they don't even matter. They're rounding errors. But with a Gdpr type legislation. You know, privacy has to be important, because if I lose, if I lose the court cases, basically after the end of the day, I could be liable for 4% of global revenue which is in the multi billions of dollars for these companies.
Classroom 410: All right. Next question, we'll just go hot. Takes. Now I have a question about the right to be forgotten thing, so if he is able to do it in Europe, or whatever, how does that
Classroom 410: like, would it only be for, like European sites, or does it also apply to like
Classroom 410: American sites too? If you
Classroom 410: so in theory it applies to American sites as well. So there's a you know, every company, every website that you visit right now, you have the banner that makes you opt in and select cookies. There's no law in the United States that says anything about that, because I'm doing business with potential EU citizens is one of the reasons why the University of Virginia has to deal with Gdpr. Is because we have EU citizens that are our customers here.
Classroom 410: So in theory, when a block as big as the EU does something like this. It can affect companies worldwide.
Classroom 410: Apac, Asia, Pacific economic consortium has very similar laws. You know, it's not as famous as Gdpr, but
Classroom 410: yeah, so if you're gonna do multinational business, you have to worry about Gdp.
Classroom 410: all right. The hot take hot. Take
Classroom 410: consumers vote with their feet. They want to give up privacy, convenience. What's the possible harm?
Classroom 410: Who in here has Gmail, who in here read that agreement?
Classroom 410: I have free email from Gmail, is that a
Classroom 410: I I'm giving up my privacy for that service. What's the possible harm anybody got a hot take on that.
Classroom 410: I mean, it's your data, you're willingly giving it up. What's the problem? Maybe if you have like a great idea, for example, you're emailing someone about it.
Classroom 410: in a sense, since you're giving up that data for Gmail to have if someone doesn't come across or someone in Google, maybe they could use it and say, it's their data.
Classroom 410: So you're saying, there's a possible downside to this.
Classroom 410: So the agreement that you signed when you signed up for a Gmail account so that they can read your email.
Classroom 410: Does that bother anybody anybody ever think twice about that?
Classroom 410: You know, if you don't want to, there's a couple of takes on this. I'll open up the room. Any other thoughts on this statement.
Classroom 410: So consumers can choose not to do business with companies if they're concerned about their data practices, right?
Classroom 410: Can they or can they not?
Classroom 410: I mean, I feel like at this point. Most people expect that most of their data is just kind of like accessible by anyone.
Classroom 410: At least, that's kind of what I think. And so it's kind of like a yeah gmail gets into whatever, because it's already up there.
Classroom 410: So I'll ask it to the roof. Does anyone have an expectation of privacy anymore? Electronically.
Classroom 410: because who does not raise your hands? If you, if you think along the same lines that
Classroom 410: somebody's gonna be looking at my data at some point. I shouldn't expect it.
Classroom 410: Cool, cynical room. Okay? I like it. So we have no expectations of privacy.
Classroom 410: Any other takes on this.
Classroom 410: Alright, we'll go on to the next step.
Classroom 410: Law enforcement should be able to access every device they save lives every day. With this information.
Classroom 410: anybody have a reaction to that statement. I see a head shake.
Classroom 410: Yeah, I disagree.
Classroom 410: I think I think
Classroom 410: as a company, especially like a like a tech. I think in cases like a technology provider
Classroom 410: kind of like sign a contract with your customers that you're gonna protect their like, safeguard their data. And although I do get that like some crime is is
Classroom 410: sneak in through text or whatever it be, I think that you still have to like preserve that, because.
Classroom 410: like, that's just the reality of like a contract. I mean.
Classroom 410: you can't just get out of a contract just because you think someone's doing wrong. But I do think, however, like
Classroom 410: I don't know, I'm trying to think back to the example of I don't know what the attack was when they found them through like his application, like, there's multiple occasions of that.
Classroom 410: If it's like a terrorist threat or something like that. I do get that. I think companies should be able to release it in the event of like
Classroom 410: it's see, it's for the
Classroom 410: the safety of like the greater community I do get in that sense. But I don't think it should just be like constantly
Classroom 410: looked over and stuff like that. Okay, so you may say there's an intervention, perhaps a warrant right, and at that point you would open the doors. I guess the other flip side to this is like
Classroom 410: you also hope that, like as a company, these like law enforcement agencies are like working in the best interest of like
Classroom 410: consumers, citizens of also like.
Classroom 410: you know, it's also like setting a certain level of trust with them. Because, like.
Classroom 410: if it's denied, obviously, like, you know, customers would probably be happy. But like
Classroom 410: then I feel like it can only open the door, for like more questions, and, like
Classroom 410: other thoughts that, like these law enforcement agencies can have is like, why aren't they doing that? And like, I feel like we just have a negative reputation as well. So where are you on the statement itself.
Classroom 410: probably, like on the side of
Classroom 410: it. Can. It can be good to that good step?
Classroom 410: More cut?
Classroom 410: I think there's a case to be made for agreeing with this statement, because law enforcement is probably not out there constantly searching
Classroom 410: people's randomly random people's information. You'd think that they'd be going after whatever. But all it takes is one bad apple, so I would fall in the sense. I don't think the 3rd party doctrine under the 4th Amendment should
Classroom 410: allow for warrantless search of people's devices or people's data from 3rd party companies, and the burden shouldn't lie on us as individuals to constantly prove our innocence. The burden should lie on law enforcement to find the probable cause that allows them to execute searches within the like
Classroom 410: bounds of the 4th Amendment, as it was written originally. All right. So we're back to warrant. You know, we need a court. We need a warrant. We need to follow the justice system to compel
Classroom 410: keep going.
Classroom 410: I definitely understand
Classroom 410: that point, and I think where it gets kind of tricky. But when I like, when I saw this question
Classroom 410: last night, I was thinking that if law enforcement is able to like track all of your devices, and that's going to be like publicly known to everyone, it's not like they can do this in secret or secretly have this power. And I was just thinking that it would really kind of harm the law enforcement agencies, because they would probably just get so many more attempted cyber attacks from people who like bad criminals, know they have access to like
Classroom 410: everyone's information. And so it's really going to weaken their own cybersecurity, because we'll have to have so much better cybersecurity to block all the threats that this would just bring to them. This is a fantastic point. Once there's a backdoor.
Classroom 410: there's a back door so can apple open your phones.
Classroom 410: Can they unencrypt your phone?
Classroom 410: Can they?
Classroom 410: Can they unencrypt your icloud storage.
Classroom 410: Yeah, they can do that. Can they get onto your physical device?
Classroom 410: You guys think so. But they cannot. So encryption is encryption. They don't have a magic back door. So Tim Cook.
Classroom 410: when asked about it, is basically saying, You know, this is about the San Bernardino shooting where they compelled Apple to basically unlock a terrorist's phone and Apple said, We can't.
Classroom 410: that we have no way of doing that.
Classroom 410: And we wouldn't do it if we could, because if we open a backdoor to the point made, then there's a back door.
Classroom 410: and that back door is a wicked problem, because it means that it's a backdoor. Once there's 1 backdoor, there's always a way to assist them.
Classroom 410: Neat. Oh, so last question and we'll talk about cyber crime.
Classroom 410: should security researchers. So these are people we actually met one of them that's trying to hack hardware. So if he finds a way to break into something, should he be selling that to the government or law enforcement.
Classroom 410: and doesn't matter which government 1st takes.
Classroom 410: So Joe Grand, who was literally in front of you, showing off how he was hacking hardware. Should he do that? And if he finds something, should he sell it to the Government? I feel it's just kind of like the bug program that we learned how like, where, like some companies like hire people to like search for bugs in their system. So I don't think like researchers should sell the flaws. But the Government, like wanted to hire people to identify flaws. I think that would be like.
Classroom 410: so they can do it. So the and the Government does this. By the way, some of the things that we saw early on in the semester, with not Petya. Those vulnerabilities in windows were found by the Nsa. Found by Tau, found by our offensive security people. And why do they keep them secret? Is so they can use them, you know, for espionage. They can break into machines with these tools.
Classroom 410: Doesn't matter. Let's go back. To which one does it matter which government I sell an exploit to. Should I only sell it to the Us. Or possibly Canada? Probably not Canada
Classroom 410: or can I sell it to Russia or Saudi Arabia or Iran? Does it matter?
Classroom 410: I mean, if I'm selling one of these vulnerabilities, can I sell it to whoever I want to? Whoever's gonna pay me the most?
Classroom 410: I mean, I think it matters depending on what your goal of selling it is like. If you want to make the most money, then you're not gonna only sell it like the Us. Because you'll make more money off of it, selling it to like Russia or China, or someone like that.
Classroom 410: But if you're kind of trying to follow like a moral code. Then you
Classroom 410: probably would want to like sell it to a government that you like more align with, but at the same time kind of all the governments would use it to kind of conduct surveillance on each other. So it's kind of
Classroom 410: what's around each other, right?
Classroom 410: So
Classroom 410: these are wicked problems for a reason they don't have simple answers. I appreciate you talking about it. These devices exist so Apple can't break into your phone. But you know, 3rd party, Israeli companies can
Classroom 410: and they sell these devices to law enforcement so they can break into phones. They
Classroom 410: sell these to governments like Saudi Arabia to break into journalists, funds? All of these things exist.
Classroom 410: So I can break into one apple iphone with a device, one.
Classroom 410: How much do you think it costs to break into that one phone?
Classroom 410: We've got a guess.
Classroom 410: Is it $50? 50 bucks? Alright, anybody high, higher, lower 50 bucks, 1 5,050 bucks.
Classroom 410: Try a hundred, $50,000.
Classroom 410: You know, breaking this, you know, military grade encryption on devices is not easy.
Classroom 410: And so when law enforcement is going to this, they have a really good idea that they're going to find something on a device.
Classroom 410: But these. You know these types of devices. You can go buy them. Now, there's a number of different security research firms that can break into hardware devices like your iphone or your Mac, and how do they do it? They exploit things in the hardware. They exploit vulnerabilities in Bluetooth to gain access to iphones. You know. How do they do it? It's it's hard to say
Classroom 410: it's a reminder. This is exactly what Joe Brand does right? He was sending electro pulses into chips to find vulnerabilities.
Classroom 410: He's doing it to unlock. He was doing it for the power of the good.
Classroom 410: But these are the same types of folks who
Classroom 410: unlock phones for a variety of reasons he was unlocking phones for cryptocurrency. What's the difference here? Right? What's the difference?
Classroom 410: So one Israeli firm is celebrate
Classroom 410: one of the things that law enforcement has to deal with is they can take your phone. They can use one of the things they can break into it, but because the company will never say how they broke into it.
Classroom 410: It's probably not admissible in court.
Classroom 410: And so, even if law enforcement is doing this, they may never actually be able to use that evidence in court, because it was, you know, who's to say they didn't plant that evidence because there's no chain of custody because there's no actual disclosure of how they broke into a phone.
Classroom 410: We would do this. But we're not so just show of hands. I will give up my privacy for free services like email and social media show of hands. Who says, yes, we all do it right.
Classroom 410: I will give up my privacy for my safety.
Classroom 410: So I I'm okay with government surveillance. As long as it keeps me safe.
Classroom 410: raise them high. If that's your answer
Classroom 410: a little less, little less clear.
Classroom 410: Okay.
Classroom 410: alright. Well, thank you all. So we'll turn real quickly into cyber crime. And just some of the facts around cybercrime right now.
Classroom 410: 10.5 trillion dollars annually. That is larger than the damage inflicted by all natural disasters on Earth
Classroom 410: cybercrime. It's pretty amazing, and it's more profitable than all the illicit drug trade. So if any of you are thinking about becoming drug dealers, cybercrime, that's the way to go
Classroom 410: cyber security. We've crossed a trillion dollars part of the reason. As we entered this room back in September, I said, Abe, always be employed. It's because of cyber criminals. So many cyber security professionals because of the bad guys
Classroom 410: and ransomware damages have crested 20 billion dollars in terms of those you know, specific ransomware attacks.
Classroom 410: So who's getting attacked? Well, you might imagine who's getting attacked. But these different organizations are getting attacked in different ways. But basically the store to this Pwc survey is basically everybody's under attack.
Classroom 410: No industry is safe. Everybody has data. Everybody can be subject to mass ransomware
Classroom 410: who are the biggest victims of cybercrime.
Classroom 410: Well, it's the UK,
Classroom 410: really. Yeah. So the Uk has the most prevalence of individuals falling victim to cyber crime. The second, most common
Classroom 410: United States average of $38,000 lost per incident on a personal level
Classroom 410: should give you a little bit of pause.
Classroom 410: Romance scams, which are, I'm sure that some of our grandfathers are falling for that right now. But the idea that there are beautiful young ladies or beautiful young men that really want to be your partner. You just need to send them some money. Sounds funny when you say it out loud. This is a huge, huge problem
Classroom 410: we have in past years when we've had the FBI or secret service in here. That's what they talk about most, because that is how money is being separated, especially from older Americans into some of these romance scams.
Classroom 410: Cyber insurance is going up dramatically spending on cyber insurance. Because, how do we? How do we deal with risk we insure against it. That is a lot of things. If you go into this field there are a lot of cyber risk and audit positions within companies to actually assess you know how we should price cyber insurance based on your cyber security posture
Classroom 410: who has cyber insurance? Well, the Americas. So we are the biggest victims of cyber crime. Right? So we actually spend a lot of money on cyber insurance
Classroom 410: criminal activities. So what are the bad guys doing? Well, we talked about this before in attacks, you know, ransomware distributed Nile of service. 0 day attacks as well as phishing. Lately there is a crypto. Mining is on the rise again, so I can mine cryptocurrency. All I need is cycles on a machine, while I break into lots of machines, and I use that to mine cryptocurrency for me.
Classroom 410: So we've seen over the years. As the price of Bitcoin goes up, we see a lot more cryptocurrency type crime where people are basically breaking into a machine, not for the data on that machine, but the ability to use that machine.
Classroom 410: What's the most common way that companies get breached
Classroom 410: social engineering. Okay, I'm gonna go easier fishing. Right? So fishing.
Classroom 410: So, fishing is the most common way that we get it. You know, we attack the human humans are easier to attack than people.
Classroom 410: Malware incidents are obviously through the roof.
Classroom 410: We talked about ransomware and the dangers posed by ransomware.
Classroom 410: Last year
Classroom 410: last year Chris Krebs was here, so we got a chance to chat with him on a bunch of things. He is the former director of Cisa, who was fired by President Trump via Tweet
Classroom 410: famously. But he talked to me about this, he said. Ransomware is enabled by 3 things. One is.
Classroom 410: you know, vulnerable systems that we've talked about. How do we, the 5 pillars of cyber hiding like? How do we not get compromised? But we need other things. We need the ability to extract value. So if there weren't for digital currencies and untraceable financial transactions, ransomware would exist.
Classroom 410: And then we need a state stable base of operations which, as we'll see in a second, is basically in foreign countries that don't really care if you're attacking different corporations in the United States, because it might actually help our geopolitical.
Classroom 410: This is old, but average breach. These numbers are here, you know, massive numbers associated with breaches and mega breaches. In particular. Mega means that I've lost over a million records which are all too common
Classroom 410: and time to identify. You know these numbers are from earlier in the semester, but people, the bad guys are breaking into systems and they're sitting. They're in the systems for a long time before discovery.
Classroom 410: All right. So where do cyber attacks originate. Who's got a guess?
Classroom 410: What do you think? The number one place for where the bad guys are based?
Classroom 410: China, China? Okay, what else? Russia? Okay? Look Russian China. Yeah, that's 1 and 2.
Classroom 410: Russia is, you know, has
Classroom 410: army units. They're basically part of the government. They also have huge networks of cyber gangs.
Classroom 410: China is more sophisticated. A lot of the hacking that they do is done by government units.
Classroom 410: and so Russia and China are one and 2. We look down the list. It's the usual suspects
Classroom 410: the biggest surprise on the end. Here is the United States. And so a lot of cyber attacks actually originate from the United States, because we have the best infrastructure for attacks like that who has the second best infrastructure in the world. South Korea. So also places to launch things like Ddos attacks because we have lots of ability to do it
Classroom 410: alright. So we're running out of time. So I'll go quick.
Classroom 410: But we're losing about 654,000 records per day companies.
Classroom 410: There are 24,000 mobile apps, malicious mobile apps that are attempted to be posted to the apple and the play store every single day
Classroom 410: that are denied by Google and Apple.
Classroom 410: There are about 3 billion passwords in use.
Classroom 410: 60% of all fraud actually comes from mobile devices. So your mobile device is on your person at all times. You may be just waking up. You may be intoxicated. You always have your mobile device. So it's a great way to attack people.
Classroom 410: And lastly, 0 point 0 5% point 0 5% is the likelihood that a cybercrime
Classroom 410: is detected and prosecuted.
Classroom 410: So one, it's super profitable. Don't go into drug dealing. Go into cyber crime. And 2, you have a very, very low chance of going to jail.
Classroom 410: because there's so much of it. It's not prosecuted in any way.
Classroom 410: So who is fighting cybercrime? Well, the lead is the FBI. So the FBI cares about one thing they don't care about getting you back in business they don't care about, you know, making sure your customers are happy. They care about catching the bad guy.
Classroom 410: So the FBI, when they lead a response, they might actually confiscate all your servers because they want to do forensics on them to catch the bad guy. They do not care about your business operations. They want to catch the bad guys.
Classroom 410: The FBI maintains lists of cyber criminals. These are the most wanted criminals in the world. Our number one here is the guy that created a fake, basically
Classroom 410: a fake application for cleaning off things off your hard drive, you know, when you we talked last time about hey? How do I rid my machine? Well, they have a fake one, and they installed it on hundreds of millions of machines. And so he's the number one cyber criminal in the world
Classroom 410: cat teams so much like cert you heard the hurt teams from Cisa. That is what M. Leads. Cat teams are cyber response teams that are on site within 24 h. If there's a cyber incident, the FBI will be there with all their year, all their forensics, etc.
Classroom 410: So, in addition to the FBI, the Secret Service is majorly involved in cybercrime, because the Secret Service, in addition to protecting the President, is in charge of the money supply. So any interstate commerce, fraud, wire, fraud. All involves the Secret Service.
Classroom 410: There is a 30 agencies partnering together in a cybercrime initiative since 2,008
Classroom 410: these are neat folks. I'd love to talk about them more. But we're almost out of time.
Classroom 410: How do we report a crime? That's important. Before we finish up the semester website.
Classroom 410: go to the website.
Classroom 410: So if you think you're a victim of a cyber crime, you literally go to the FBI's website and you fill out a form that is the best way to get a response from the Federal agencies.
Classroom 410: You can do that with us. Cert with Cisa M's group. You can do that with IC 3, which is the FBI site, you basically file a complaint. I've actually done this because my
Classroom 410: father-in-law was actually victim of a scam. And it's not the most rewarding process. I'll just say it that way. But this is actually how you report crimes
Classroom 410: all right. 2 min left, which is good. So final. Exam. Professor Wright led today talking about it. That's a little bit more detail. Obviously, this is in the slides.
Classroom 410: When I say, Be smart about external resources. It means be organized before you start the exam.
Classroom 410: Everything is open game.
Classroom 410: Every lecture is recorded. It's posted on canvas. All the materials are there. If you want to use external sources, it's fine, but I will warn you that it can cost you time. If you're using resources in a bad way
Classroom 410: you're welcome to use AI or Google. But sometimes that's not going to get you to the answer that you want that time
Classroom 410: cool. 3 more things, one equifax. Second round of payments came out yesterday for anyone affected.
Classroom 410: I got 1 $7 and 44 cents. So I my kids are getting that for Christmas.
Classroom 410: Second point is, course, Evals, please fill out the Eval. You like what we do. You know what we do? We just want your feedback. It's worth a point on the final exam. So everybody that finishes the course. Eval will get an extra point on the final exam
Classroom 410: and stay in touch.
Classroom 410: So we want to, you know, as you've seen from this classroom, you're the you drive this. So you're going to be out in the world. We want to stay in touch with you. Please connect with myself and Professor Wright, because we want to hear about what you're doing in the world.
Classroom 410: Thanks, everybody.
Classroom 410: 14.
Classroom 410: Let's see.
Classroom 410: Yeah, this is fucking hard.
Classroom 410: So I drove back to Bridge.